A few weeks ago, I was looking through records
in the British National Archives
for a separate video idea that
didn't end up going anywhere,
but while I was researching I found
a completely different report,
secret and restricted when it was written
but now unclassified,
and it's the first time in a long while
that I've read some old archive file
and my jaw has literally dropped.
It was called:
"Possible Sites for Completely Contained
Nuclear Explosions in North Yorkshire."
North Yorkshire is a beautiful area
that includes two national parks.
This is the middle of one of them.
It is stunning, it is historic,
it is not somewhere that I'd
expect anyone to try and
set off a nuclear explosion.
The report was written in June 1969,
so just for context,
we're talking full Space Race,
white-heat-of-technology era.
Neil Armstrong would set foot on the moon
only about a month after that report was written.
And the report is talking about
Peaceful Nuclear Explosions.
Which was an idea that was in fashion
among some nuclear scientists
and policy makers at the time.
Maybe, the theory went, we could create
artificial harbours and canals
using nuclear bombs.
No more years of mechanical digging,
just put a few well-placed nukes
in the ground and, boom, boom, boom,
there's your new canal.
Or maybe we could help stimulate
production in gas wells,
basically nuclear fracking.
Or, and this was charitably
the most practical idea,
create enormous underground cavities
for gas storage,
instead of having to use
big above-ground tanks.
The US did run a couple of dozen
nuclear tests like that
under the rather Biblical title
"Operation Plowshare".
The Soviet Union eventually
ran more than 200.
But those are stories that have already
been told by a lot of other people.
By the 1970s, the US and the Soviets
would work out that it was a bad idea:
if you use a nuke, either for fracking,
or to create underground gas storage,
the radiation ends up
contaminating the gas.
But until that was figured out...
well, I don't think many people
have actually noticed the records about it
since it was declassified,
but it turns out at least some people
in the UK were interested as well.
Those people worked at the Gas Council,
and the Atomic Weapons Research Establishment,
and the report shows that they were
seriously trying to work out
if nuclear bomb gas storage caverns
were a good idea.
I kept researching, and found they'd
commissioned a full study,
laying out the pros and cons, comparing
the cost to other methods of storage.
They had picked a site.
Which was here.
Actually, literally, exactly there,
bottom of that ravine.
Wheeldale, in the middle of the
North Yorkshire Moors National Park.
The plan was: buy all the land
for about a mile around.
Drill down 2,000 feet,
about 600 metres,
with a special extra-wide drill bit,
big enough so they could drop a
25 kiloton nuclear bomb
down to the bottom of the hole.
I say "drop". Lower.
That's a big enough bomb to
annihiliate a city in the open air.
Plug up the hole, cover the top so
nothing comes out, hopefully.
Evacuate the thousand or so people
who live nearby, just in case.
And then... boom.
Not much would happen on the surface.
There'd be a bit of a jolt and a rumble,
a few birds startled into the air.
The local towns of Pickering and Whitby,
about ten miles away each,
they'd feel a minor earthquake,
and maybe a couple of buildings would
get a few small cracks in them.
I'm not kidding, that's what the report
actually says,
it just phrases it a little
bit more delicately than that.
It's not clear whether the locals would
actually have been told what was going on,
but I think it would have
been impossible to hide.
After that, they would let the giant cavern
that had been created 600 metres down
cool for a few months, and then
flush out and remove
most of the radioactive stuff
that was left behind,
which it turns out would have been
a lot more difficult than
they thought at the time.
Finally, they'd put some pumping equipment
in here at the top, and presto,
giant underground high-pressure gas
storage tank for relatively not much money.
And after a couple of years, they can
sell most of this land back.
Cost of the explosion, in today's money,
adjusted for inflation: about nine million pounds.
Which is... not actually bad for a
giant gas storage tank?
I suspect that was a very
optimistic estimate, though.
Even that was more expensive than setting up
liquid natural gas storage above ground,
but once you've the made the cavern,
it's much cheaper to run this way.
If, that is the explosion works as predicted.
And if there's really no radiation left over.
There were a lot of risks.
Now, as far as I can tell,
this never got anywhere near
the Prime Minister's desk,
there was never some high-up government meeting
trying to work out whether they should
nuke a bit of a national park.
I suspect it would have been
a very bad political decision.
And a very bad environmental decision.
And a very bad financial decision.
And... look, I'm sure there is some
possible alternate history where this happened,
but things would need to
have been very different.
The last reference I could find
is from November 1969.
The plan was worked out in theory,
and the minutes of the meeting from then
say that "further thought would be given
to what action should follow".
And at some point, in some other
record that I missed,
or maybe that is still restricted,
I'm sure there'll be a note that says
they decided not to pursue the idea.
Peaceful nuclear explosions would
eventually be banned by treaty,
conveniently just after the point
at which the US and Russia
found out they weren't a great idea.
And the North Yorkshire Moors,
thankfully, were never nuked.